ja ich sage ich wir in jeder krise
steckt eine chance und die haben wir
jetzt genutzt und bin sehr stolz auf
diesen schritt was sie damals gesagt
haben
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen zum sportplatz dem
sport podcast des österreichischen
bundesheers heute zu gast frau zugführer
magdalena lobnig servus hallo und nicht
nur dass du da bist sondern du hast auch
gepäck mitgenommen ist eine
bronzemedaille aus total mitgenommen
herzliche gratulation auf jeden fall
einmal dazu erzählen mal wie war das für
dich endlich diesen großen traum zu
erfüllen ihr dankeschön erster sommer
und ja wie war das für mich riesengroße
erleichterung
also ganz große last von meinen
schultern auf queen wieder durchs ziel
gefahren bin und
riesen riesengroße freude und jetzt wie
sie da noch so da liegen sie quasi erst
gar nicht an also es ist natürlich ein
lebenstraum in erfüllung geht wie lang
kannst du ungefähr beziffern dass du
dich explizit für dieses ziel
vorbereitet hast wie viele jahre harte
arbeit ist da hinein gegangen damit du
dir diesen traum der olympia- medaille
erfüllen kannst ja also wir oder ja
mittlerweile schon seit 15 jahren so
explizit das mal auf so olympia-medaille
hinarbeitet jetzt ist ein trio so wo ist
realistischer granit in rio war sechster
und das war bislang deutschland aber die
nächsten spieler wurde die absolut
bessere abschneiden und ja ich sage mir
die letzten fünf jahre ist das richtig
richtig konkret wurden wie ist es dir im
verlaufe des wettkampfs gegangen was ich
mitbekommen es geht gut du fühlst dich
gut wie kann man sich darunter
vorstellen bekommt man damit ich kann
das ich mache das jetzt mit einem
riesengroßen selbstvertrauen natürlich
nachdruck york wo sie am anfang keine
fehler gemacht der vorbereitung und das
hat mir einen riesengroßen brust geben
und dann bin ja unten das erste rennen
gefahren und haben wir die
zweitschnellste zeit gebracht und die
vorlaufzeiten wird man natürlich auch
diese vergleichen im rudern wo ist er
autor sport ist und man immer vorsichtig
sein muss aber ja das hat mir natürlich
dann noch haben wir jetzt mehr
selbstvertrauen geben man sagt okay
jetzt auch noch cool bleiben und die
einzelnen läufe top arbeiten bis sie ins
finale kommen und dann halt volle
attacke und wie bleibt man da cool ich
meine das jetzt aus meinem sport dem
schwimmen aber wie schafft man es wenn
man da jetzt die zeit schon ist derzeit
eben gesagt das team im verlauf hatten
und dann macht man sich schon gedanken
und man sieht das ist realistisch wie
bleibt man da cool und lässt sich nicht
wahnsinnig machen vom gefährt von der
erwartung von der eigenen erwartung
vielleicht wirst du das gemacht und ja
das war natürlich nicht ganz einfach
weil es war ja viertelfinale wartet aufs
halbfinale das halbfinale war natürlich
richtig schwer sowie gegen damen treten
wir sind die olympia finale heute gut
gewissen werden und das zu überleben war
natürlich auch bei der hauptkommissar
wieder kleines vorfinale und ja doch
ganz schnell wieder opfer von dem floh
in dem das neue trainings und da ist
eine sehr große nervosität und angst
drinnen und ja aber da du kriegst du
einen focus eine tür zum finale und dann
natürlich auf das finalrennen und sie
war das ziemlich in alle dann selbst das
war ja härter auch für dich und wie geht
man dann wenn man das dann geschafft hat
man weiß man diesem finale wird man dann
in dieser situation damit ja das
semifinale aber natürlich hammerhart und
das war klar von den namen her dass das
richtig zu erklären wird und ich bin der
seine zwerge hat also bis die ersten
1000 die waren eigentlich ganz gut aber
wenn die zeiten 1000 bisschen party
wieder reinkommen eigentlich was mir
ganz gut liegen sollte da habe ich habe
keinen vorteil daraus ziehen können und
ja das hat mir dann so richtig
wachgerüttelt für das finalrennen bin
leider auf die außenbahn gerutscht durch
einen dritten platz ins semifinale und
war da schon ein bisschen nervös gemacht
war neuville kg sowie von rio war es
ganz gleich der bin jahr im semifinale
dritte geworden war auf der außenbahn
und du kriegst vom rennen wenig mit
außer durch die konkurrentin was du
heute neben der horst rau besteht quasi
immer auf der außenbahn heute im außen
fällt und dann habe aber versucht das
übrigens positive für mieter ziehen und
habe gedacht was das vielleicht das ist
ganz schlecht so kann ich mich auf mich
selbst konzentrieren
bleib bei mir ein boot ich habe die
wichtigste konkurrentin die britin um
diese bronzemedaille und die
realistische die habe direkt nebenan tja
genauso bin in einem finale also man
direkt an aus seinem vermeintlichen
nachteil ein vorteil gemacht war das
vielleicht auch das erfolgsgeheimnis sei
jetzt einmal gibt es wahrscheinlich
nicht aber war das vielleicht auch
ausschlaggebend dass du dann die
außenbahn hattest und mit dieser
einstellung so ins rennen gegangen bist
ja er hat gedacht okay bei die zwar die
em medaillen die was er schon von einem
hof im vorfeld da war ja jeweils auf der
außenbahn und der halben jahr selbst
konzentrieren kann hat er dass das ist
vielleicht genau meinst du vielleicht
braucht es ja nicht nur bei mir da kann
ich voll ans limit gehen ja vielleicht
sogar überraschen auf der außenbahn das
jahr wieder vorne weg fahren und genauso
wie es angelegt im finale bin ja schon
eine stadt fahren und habe ich geschaut
dass bis 1000 nur bei mir im boot
bleiben und akustik her bringt ihnen
diesen gut hinter mir 1000 aber ist erst
einmal ein check gemacht habe die seiten
ein [ __ ] okay ich bin zweiter jetzt nur
cool bleiben hat deshalb bringen ist
dieser check nicht nicht auch gefährlich
also wenn man dann den blick macht und
sich dann vielleicht wahnsinnig machen
lässt wenn man sieht dass wir leute
vielleicht nicht so wie ich es möchte
oder wenn man dann schon zu sicher ist
kann das passieren oder seid ihr da so
auch mental darauf eingestellt dass
diese gedanken da gar nicht mit mir
ankommen können ja also wenn es gut
läuft gibt es dann natürlich an putzt
und da warst du kapierst du bist es
fuhren und du fühlst du vielleicht noch
sehr gut wenn du hinten bis dann gibt es
da und bewusst wenn er war ist jetzt
muss sie anfangs zulegen und da quasi
das feld von hinten aufrollen aber
soweit wurde bewusst der staat
tatsächlich die gut geführt die bin
richtig wird den strecken schlag eine
kommen und ich habe ja vor sehr
flüssigen bewegung gefühlt und ihr habt
eine ausnahme sagt okay mir geht's gut
liegt jetzt einfach nur weitermachen und
dann ist die attacke von abriet in
kommern antreten 500 wie es halt gemacht
habe wie es mit dem trainer abgesprochen
waren da wir dagegenhalten und hinten du
deinen entsperrt gemacht und der ist
hier davon ja chance gehabt und dann
wirst du durch ziel gekommen also sofort
realisiert dass es so weit ist dass es
geschafft hast oder hat das ein bisschen
gebraucht und ja ich weiß ich hab
eigentlich 1500 da quasi beim letzten
streckenviertel habe ich schon merkt das
los im märz nahm man jemand und mein
trainer ist im auto mitgefahren und der
hat einen riesengroßen brüder
losgelassen
bewusst der sich schon richtig gut das
von der körpersprache her und vom willen
und
drei minuten für die ewigkeit dabei
läuft und die harvey durchgezogen also
drei minuten quasi die die minuten was
am meisten wehtun quasi im ruderrennen
und ja ich bin ein übers ziel über die
ziellinie gefahren und natürlich sofort
dann
erleichtern dann schreit losgelassen und
hatte eine kurze nacht mancher ist jetzt
haben wir für ein ausdruck aber
vielleicht stimmt gar nicht und habe
dann wartet aufs display auf der seiten
bis 3 erscheint und dann was die
realität ja dass er dafür gestimmt und
die erleichterung war riesengroß das
kann man sich gar nicht ich kann nur
versuchen vorzustellen was für emotionen
in diesem moment durch durchgegangen
haben es dann auch im fernsehinterview
gesehen wie emotional gewusst wie
glücklich dass es geklappt hat welche
eindrücke sind dann nach dem
medaillengewinn auf dich eingeflossen
was hast du alles erlebt und wie hast du
das alles wahr genommen hatte schönste
war eigentlich die ganzen team
mitglieder es war so vielleicht vom
olympic team austria dauert haben sie
also für mich frei da war meine
konkurrentin anja das hat mir jeder
morgen tag sagte glückwunsch können wird
das war so schön deswegen das eigentlich
es hat mir jeder diese mit allen fakten
da wo ja das war so hart erarbeitet und
jeder weiß dass wieder eine gesteckt
habe und
einfach schön zu sehen dass die freunde
so groß ist
was glaubst du verändert sich jetzt für
dich durch den medaillengewinnen mal für
mich noch immer gleich wie vorher aber
ja natürlich voller stolz das geschafft
zu haben stück sportgeschichte für
österreich geschrieben das erfüllt mich
mit stolz und
johanna seitz bin ja sehr traurig dass
diese reise jetzt zu ende ist dieselbe
route tokio
die ist jetzt vorbei und ist dabei die
abschlussfeier die offizielle und der
war schon ein bisschen emotional muss
ich ganz ehrlich sagen es war doch so
ein lebenstraum den mann jetzt gelebt
hat und jetzt muss man schauen dass man
sich auch unseres ziel steckt welcher
form auch immer
bin natürlich neugierig was jetzt die
zukunft bringt auf die weiteren ziele da
kommen wir gleich da hatte ich natürlich
nicht raus aber in diesem ganzen druck
die olympische spiele paket gar
natürlich auch verschiedenste empfänge
und
wahrscheinlich auch in der heimat dann
noch gut gefeiert und zu recht gefeiert
all diese dinge wenn du das siehst wie
viele menschen für dich mitgefiebert
haben mich unterstützt haben wie nimmst
du das war
es war echt überwältigend also wie war
das erste mal war schon am flughafen
sprosse vielleicht auch gewartet haben
in der halle zu sehen das im moment
natürlich waren ja wir waren ja mit
judoka mit 23 meter länge wiener wollen
wir da am flughafen und die ganze halle
aber voller leid und alle haben sich
gefreut wir uns das was so schön zu
sehen dass dieser gemeinsame gedanke und
diesen erfolg zu feiern
das zu teilen es war wunderbar natürlich
dann da haben war natürlich auch noch
zwei schöne ist ja sehr schöne empfänger
und wir haben jemanden einen korb weil
es ist so schön so herzlich empfangen zu
werden und jeder weiß eben was du da
durchgemacht hast und ja dass die leute
ist damit gefallen das ist ja es gibt
nichts schöneres gehabt das war ja auch
den zusammenhalt angesprochen auch im
kern im team du hast ja schon erfahrung
zum beispiel aus rio wo sich sogar den
unterschied zu den spielen 2016 und
jetzt
2021 geben die zwanziger spiele vor
allem unter den umständen und der
schwierige situation die wahrscheinlich
für viele in der vorbereitung nicht
einfach war wo hast du da unterschiede
wahrgenommen ja also zusammen heute im
team war für mich persönlich ganz genau
wie in rio noch vielleicht war die wahl
noch zu jung und habe das sind wie
anders wahrgenommen vielleicht hat mir
das auch das große spektakel absender
schlagen aber ich glaube in rio war der
druck auf das war sondern halt doch habe
sie habe leider war für team austria und
jedoch sehnsüchtig auf die erste
medaille geortet und wo im final kommt
ob da war noch gar nicht alle dort dann
auf einmal die ganze persönlichkeit dar
auf der tribüne und erwarten was von dir
der ganze fokus ist auf an selbst
richtet und das war schon schwer
auszuhalten und dann erfährt man noch
schlecht in einem final rennen und dann
gibt es vielleicht eine böse
schlagzeilen die machen das ganze nicht
leichter zu verarbeiten und damit tokio
war es schon
sehr leicht an dass das ist einfach
schon mit allen im vorfeld gegeben hat
und das war einfach sehr impressive zu
sehen dass diana kiss innovatives die
gut eine kult hat aus dem nichts das
vieh war so gerührt da im zimmer wo er
das verfolgt habt ja das ist ja wahnsinn
dies ist also die entschuldigung die
chefs haben nichts die freitag vorneweg
die wassermusik das hat mir so imponiert
und dann die judoka also silva mit eine
bronze medaille her wir haben es absolut
drauf wie sonst war kleines land aber
wir können dafür den mit weiten und das
hat mir einen irrsinnigen auftrieb geben
wir mehr finalrennen gibt es dem ganzen
eine dynamik die vielleicht vorher gar
nicht kalkulierbar war die man
vielleicht auch gar nicht künstlich
irgendwie erzeugen kann dass das team
dann zusätzlich noch so motiviert ist
wenn eben gleich zu beginn solcher
erfolge sich schon einstellen ist das
etwas was hast du dich gefühlt hast ja
ich glaube absolut also da war ja in
song flow drin und die was trägt herr
die trauernde dazu ja es hat ja jeder zu
manövrieren ist mir das zugetraut aber
diesmal war es anders oriel und die hat
er jetzt bündnis auch nach bist dann
auch nach hause gekommen sehr schnell
weil ja die maßnahmen das so gesagt
haben dass die athletinnen und athleten
nach ihren wettkämpfen eigentlich sofort
abreisen müssen ist das etwas was du
vielleicht auch mit ein bisschen wehmut
gemacht hast weil soweit ich mich
erinnere dass das war einmal nachdem die
wettkämpfe bei waren war das dann
wirklich das aufsaugen der spiele wenn
man ohne druck und einfach nur genießen
kann dass man ist dabei ist dass diesmal
gefehlt ja absolut also
was da so was diese arbeit rausgerissen
also wir bei mir was hat so dass sie
heute quasi am liebsten gleich anklang
bin oder eigentlich 5 uhr 30 in der früh
es muss ja mal vorstellen da hat mir die
hellen gewinnen muss man da habt acht
stehen und abflug bereit sein es war
richtig heftig eigentlich mandat vor
allen dass man ist das arbeitet es
rausgerissen wird der mann für die
letzten zwei wochen heute früh drin
steckt das mit voller emotionen einfach
so spieler von uns mit sich bringen
heute und ich habe dann da haben
eigentlich jeden tag in der früh vor dem
fernseher eingeschaltet und olympische
spiele geschaut weil er auch wohnungs
bis das ganze sein wollt und ja das hab
ich auch im norden noch so gespielt und
heute in österreich alle verfolgten
tankwart von fernseher und so habe ich
es ein bisschen noch so wie sie auch
sagen können aber natürlich während
wissen vor ort noch zu sein aber
natürlich unter diesen umständen
trotzdem gut dass die spiele so
stattfinden kann ja nur deine leistung
auch so zeigen konnte jetzt hat das so
ein jahr mehr vorbereitungszeit das ist
von vielen schon als motive auch genannt
worden dass vielleicht ergebnisse auch
so waren du hast auch vorher gesagt dass
man in diesen schweren momenten auch
arbeiten muss damit umgehen muss
vielleicht eine negative schlagzeile
vielleicht einmal ein ergebnis das nicht
so gut ist auch dort ist in der
vergangenheit immer wieder rückschläge
gesundheitlicher natur verletzungen oder
eben wo die leistungen nicht so waren
wie du es dir gewünscht hast wie ist es
dir in diesen momenten gegangen und wie
hast du es geschafft hast du dann
trotzdem dann bleibst also für mich war
dieser turn over point war ja eigentlich
die heim-wm 2009 10 haben ja direkt
davor erkrankt und habe dann wirklich
absolut nicht meine leistung bringen
können bei der wm die was eigentlich
drauf gehabt hätte und das war's wohl
dämpfer für mich selbst die akkus damals
ich muss etwas verändern muss etwas
grundlegendes verändern und ich habe
sage dorn und bin sehr froh dass ich
diesen schritt gewagt habe da einen
eigenen team zu trainieren mit dem
trainer zu trainieren und in späterer
folge ist dieser trainer ja dann je nach
arznei drin in österreich gewann und ja
ich sage ich meinen jeder krise steckt
eine chance und die haben damals absolut
nützt und ja bin sehr stolz auf diesen
schritt was sie damals gesagt habe und
das was sie habe sie das erfolgsrezept
quasi mein trainer thomas sind im jahr
ausgestiegen ist wieder zu reaktivieren
in kombination mit dem neuen
nationaltrainer und jetzt da die
verschiebung der spieler die waren
natürlich hat große chancen weil wir
haben das training umgestellt und wir
haben gemerkt da jetzt hier bei der em
im jahr 2000 im herbst als einen guten
speed war irgendwie richtig da max pete
und wir haben dann wieder adaptiert das
training im winter und wir haben jetzt
richtig richtig fein richtung spiele
heute kennen ist das aufgegangen keine
fehler gemacht das heißt auch die
situation wirklich optimal genutzt aber
das war den mut angesprochen dass man da
veränderungen setzt das kann natürlich
auch nach hinten losgehen und wenn man
nicht mehr so viel zeit hat muss man
auch mit diesem risiko leben
wie hast du diese entscheidung getroffen
dass du was verändern muss also wie geht
es in diesem moment wo du sagst ok ich
muss das jetzt machen weil sonst keine
ahnung sehe ich vielleicht keinen
fortschritt sowie entscheidet man sowas
wie heim-wm habe ja das olympia ticket
gelöst das letzte die könnte meiner
klasse gelöst wo es gibt und ich habe
gewusst ich bin ja das ziel gefahren
bewusst okay ich hoffe das ticket bei
bin in keiner position wo er irgendwie
um medaillen kann ich war sah ich hoffe
nicht dass ungefähr dazu die muss was
verändern das ist so in mir drin steckt
ja ich hab das laut ausgesprochen gibt
es sofort mit dem verband kommuniziert
und gesagt hey wie man etwas verändern
das geht so weiter und ich habe mit mein
umfeld hat geredet mit freund und
bekannte und die haben wir alle in der
hinsicht unterstützt und ich habe dann
auch wieder schritt gewagt euch nahe bin
heute die erste wort das macht
ja es ist alles gut gar natürlich ganz
anders aus genau aber meistens sicher in
dem was ich tue und gelangte vertrauen
horst in das was du tust horst herbert
werden also entscheidend hat das ist auf
jeden fall also was vielleicht auch für
andere aber solche entscheidungen
treffen
dass auch das umfeld angesprochen dein
erfolg historisch also das ist auf jeden
fall für den österreichischen rudersport
sportgeschichte und jetzt ist die frage
was würde es brauchen damit dein erfolg
eben nicht nur historisch bleibt sondern
auch wiederholbar ist nicht nur von dir
selbst sondern das auch wirklich der der
rudersport in österreich noch weiter
aufkommt was wir das brauchen vielleicht
auch angetrieben durch eine medaille
jetzt ich hoffe natürlich dass dieser
motivationsschub für das ganze team ist
das musiktheater ist erreicht konnte die
olympischen medaillen hat ganz vorne mit
rudern und
natürlich hoffe ich dass man ein
bisschen mehr frauen natürlich meine
fußstapfen heute steigen werden das hat
natürlich dass das allerschönste er war
ja du brauchst du da wo gewisse jahre wo
der sport halt vorne mitmischen zu
können und wir haben auch sehr gutes
trainerteam jetzt da die verbandsführung
ist super also ich glaube schon dass
alles ordentlich dies um option liefern
aber natürlich die entwicklung jeder was
ist aus dem motorsport boss dass sie
hier auch die armen blog quasi im sport
ganz ganz vorne landen zu können dabei
denkt der junge nachwuchs moderator den
willen hormann glaub schon dass jetzt
einige feuer und flamme sein ja wie
olympische spiele er gesagt dass das
volk wirklich da auch intern im team was
sagen gezündet hat also absolut das
feedback was sie da kriegt davon meine
ganze kollegen ist vorwiegend und ja ich
glaube schon dass jetzt alle irgendwie
alles vielleicht so wie sie spielen
wollen und da erreichen wollen und ja
ich hoffe natürlich dass es versuchen
das auf meine nachricht dass schon
geantwortet wichtig appelliert verpasst
du es schon geschafft auf alle
nachrichten zu antworten ich fast jeden
tag vor ort zu ort worden es seien doch
durch die sozialen medien sowie chats
dazu kommen und jetzt sollen wir gerade
dabei verantwortet aber ich hoffe auf
antrag und hoetmar die zeit geben
wirklich jeder einzeln durchzulesen und
und zu antworten und das ist ein
frühchen das ist alle die zu haben oder
zu schauen und die geschrieben haben
aber noch keine antwort bekommen haben
geduld corinna ist da kommt auf jeden
fall noch was wenn jetzt einen blick in
die zukunft wirft du hast jetzt der
folge deiner team kolleginnen und
kollegen angesprochen die hoffentlich
folgen werden hoffentlich auch noch
erfolge von deiner seite was steht bei
dir jetzt noch an wenn du diesen traum
erfüllt hast wie denkst du weiter wie
denkst du die nächsten jahre zu planen
ja es ist für die schwierige frage das
ist echt orks hätte mir da in wien
gelandet wie nie die chance zur sport
waren aber ihr zweiter mann hat da nicht
ja ich will mir die zeit auf gm aber
noch darüber nachzudenken
ich bin natürlich hin und her also
anders denken wie schwer ist es
eigentlich diesen moment jetzt zu dopen
also es gibt natürlich noch silber und
gold aber die wahrscheinlichkeit dass es
noch einmal so gut wert an topix man
muss sich ja vorstellen was da jetzt
fünf jahre vorbereitungszeit und just an
dem tag der minuten muss aufpassen dass
du da ablief ist also der kirchenpfleger
dazu natürlich aber der körper muss
mitspielen der geist muss mitspielen und
natürlich eines umfeld und ich glaube
schon dass ja sorgen fort obwohl war es
die das steht zu hundert prozent noch
mal weiter aber wie gesagt ich darf noch
mal schauen was für gefühle jetzt da
sein möchte natürlich auf mein
bauchgefühl nicht verlassen und dann
entscheiden aber ich habe zu verstehen
das projekt im herbst dann möchte jetzt
bei der hosting wm mit meiner schwester
zwei staaten haben wir ganz besonderes
kisten rudern sie hatten aline pur und
mal schauen was wir erreichen können wie
ist es dazu gekommen ja wir wollten
eigentlich heuer im herbst bei der
offiziellen weltmeisterschaft im job
zwar eventuell starten und die haben
leider abgesagt aus körper nach gründen
und jetzt nochmal alter nativ extra
gesagt okay es gibt die christen oder
wm-niveau ist wieso kursräume olympisch
machen 24 28 gehabt vielleicht wollen
wir das einfach mal aus als die partie
und ja auch mal was anderes machen es
gibt nach einer partie für 20 28
wie siehst du bist ja im endeffekt als
als ruderin alleine im boots- und in dem
sind auch auf sich alleine gestellt und
jetzt auch mit einer schwester oder
streams das mit jemand anderem im boot
zu sitzen und eben nicht mehr nur auf
die eigene leistung angewiesen zu sein
ja also ich habe jetzt fast zwei jahre
ist doppel 2 rudern verstärkt märkte das
tut mir gut das ist was für ein kopf das
ist für ein körper museum das denken
etwas anders anstellen und das hat mir
natürlich gab zu dem erfolg verholfen
aber natürlich ist ja das ist eine
mannschaft dann quasi mannschaftssport
und du musst die abstimmung fand im
einer wann im doppel zwar bin ich
vielleicht die chefin im boot aber du
musst natürlich die anpassen muss das
gemeinsam halt erreichen und es ist also
abwechslung ihrer frau gern doppelt zwar
waren es macht richtig richtig viel spaß
das ist etwas was dir dann doch liegt
auch yahoo 320 macht den job zwar wie
man eine jugendjury martin puttke fahren
und ja bereits voll also die frage ein
doppelfehler ok also es gibt auf jeden
fall option endlich haben sind dafür
weitere olympische spiele das auf jeden
fall die unseren sind da das frau
angesprochen dass auch der geist passen
muss das auch der kopf mitspielen muss
das auch in der vergangenheit auch
unterstützt durch das bundesheer durch
die berufsförderung auch da was gemacht
dass gemeinsam mit mir einen mg gemacht
du hast doch ein anderes studium noch
absolviert du bist auch noch anspruch
haben auf weitere berufsförderung was
reizt dich da alles in der zukunft wo
wir dass du dich sehen beruflich was
würdest du gerne mal machen wenn das
sportlich haben die zehn jahren vorbei
sein wird
ach ja natürlich überlege jetzt sagen in
welche richtung möchte gehen und möchte
heute im herbst eine weitere ausbildung
machen aber in welcher form was jetzt
noch gar nicht das wird wahrscheinlich
nicht das studium sein da war es gibt
sich eine sportbereich also deutlich
durch mehr herzblut drin und möchte
meine erfahrungen weitergeben vielleicht
sondern auch bis sie weiterhelfen in
irgendeiner form und ja mal schauen also
das was ihm jetzt komplett offen wie wir
das eigentlich noch tokio verschieben
welche richtung ist jetzt gehen wird
aber ich bin natürlich froh dass in
einem jahr gemacht habe das war mir sehr
wichtig nach rio abschluss ein studium
zu haben um nicht in die gleiche
situation zu kommen das ist okay können
zweiter wollen oder hat gar nichts sonst
und jetzt war sie über studien wir
können daher quasi orten gehen war ja
mir macht der sport eigentlich noch viel
zu sehr spaß trainieren noch richtig
gern ihr oder richtig gerne fahrrad
wieder am wasser das erste mal seit seit
tokio und madrid machen das ist aber
sehr schöner sport dem auch das so gern
das heißt du bist nicht an dem punkt wo
du sagst bei ich mag das überhaupt nicht
mehr sehen und interessiert mich nicht
sondern ich glaube das ist ein guter ein
guter rückenwind für für weitere erfolge
siehst du dich im trainerbereich auch
ist das etwas wo du sagst war da kann
ich total aufgehen oder er nichts wo du
dich wirklich siehst ich denke jetzt
schon so oft mal im gespräch bitten also
gerne helfen eigentlich mit den nagern
helfen stark zu werden ja ich möchte ja
dass österreich in zukunft quasi im
internet vorderen platzierungen mit
rudert und ja aber gab es ist jetzt
einfach noch zu früh also vor sie dann
einmal auch mit rudern dann glaube ich
muss noch mal weg von dieser welt sehr
durch erzähle in sich und ja mal schauen
was ist noch so gibt aber immer ich
natürlich den motorsport schon in
zukunft unterstützen wenn er zurück
schoss auch auf dem weg bisher wer also
die menschen die wirklich
ausschlaggebend waren für das was du da
erreichen kommt aus dem topf aber auch
für für deinen weg für eine laufbahn
bisher war es ist natürlich absolut die
familie ist ein ganzes darstellen die
was mich auch immer unterstützt hat in
der türkei meine
320 und junioren jahre bin immer wieder
neue wege gegangen immer wieder trainer
gewechselt und er war wie immer die
unterstützung von der hand kriegt die
haben immer gut ist okay das was ich
mache das jetzt schon so richtig sein
und ja nun mal meine wege die
boxenanlage meisten kunden und natürlich
möchte mich bei meinem trainer team
bedanken weil langjähriger trainer kurt
reiter und da dann arznei trainer der
nähe der robert senz der mir meinen
kompletten tiefpunkt 2009 10 ohne zu
zögern aufgenommen heute eine
trainingsgruppe ohne irgendwie erging
leistung zu klären hat er gesagt na kost
mitmachen war danach sehr mit seiner
unterwegs sind das war so schön zu sehen
dass der mir eigentlich quasi blind
vertraut und ja natürlich habe meine
ganzen trainingspartner also ohne meine
trainingspartner wasser gegangen aber
erst 30 ja die meiste trainingspartnerin
ohne die was nie war nie so weit kommen
und du hast ja natürlich noch eine
homebase der heim und völkermarkt wurde
am wasser bis ist das auch etwas wo du
sagst da immer wieder zurückkommen druck
ist auf der ganzen welt unterwegs so
dass überall wo man sagen kann auf
dieser welt und da trotzdem wieder
zurückkommen daheim und daran was er
sein ist das etwas was dir viel gegeben
hat ja absolut also es gibt kein
besseres oder gewässer wieder in
völkermarkt und es war für mich immer
wichtig wegzufahren um diese monotonie
zu brechen das ist mir ganz wichtig und
hier vor allem in den letzten zwei
jahren merkt das tut mir richtig gut
wenn ihr immer wieder weg um agenturen
trainingsstätten heute vor und habe
meine meine runden circa wasser und das
haben ja hervor für die spieler gesagt
dass wir ein komplettes neues wasser
gewässer quasi nehmen und töten heute
trainieren und ja es hat gepasst dass
sie haben wir von anfang an wohlgefühlt
und optional war es ja genossen dass sie
die letzten zwei wochen daheim verbracht
haben jetzt bin ich dafür charakter
straße da darf eine finalrunden vor dem
highlight meines lebens der wahl ziehen
und es hat mir richtig richtig für
energie ja und jetzt auf jeden fall
alles aufgegangen vielen dank magdalena
herzliche gratulation noch einmal zu
dieser bronson teile du hast
sportgeschichte geschrieben österreich
ist stolz auf dich natürlich auch das
österreichische bundesheer und wir
hoffen natürlich auf viele weitere
erfolge wünschen aber natürlich auch
alles gute für die zukunft und bis bald
ich danke dir danke auch dass ihr wieder
mit dabei war es beim sport bis zum
nächsten mal servus
[Musik]
[Applaus]